[Music]
with a lot of ancient cultures we focus
on the Kings the aristocratic elite what
that makes up such a minor percentage of
the population I want to know what I
would have been drinking I went into a
pub 1,100 years ago my name is Travis
Rob I make really old beer Travis is in
your everyday brew man unit team have
put a spin on craft beer by taking a
look back in time to brew ancient
computer when we produced the ancient
Egyptian and ancient Peruvian beer I
made them as close as I possibly could
to exactly the way an ancient beer would
have been produced and they turned out
quite well in ancient times beer was
traditionally brewed in clay pot there
was no carbonation in the fear head a
very low alcohol content while Travis
Bruce's beer using modern equipment he
meticulously adjusts his recipes to
include ingredients used thousands of
years ago
turns out ancient beer is surprisingly
delicious
it is often presumed that the beer they
drink was very gross or unpalatable
because we want to presume they're just
dumb and don't know any better the
ancient Egyptian beer is one of my
favorite beers to drink at the end of
the a long day of work one of the
biggest challenges really in doing pure
archaeology is really defining these
recipes and brewing ancient beer on a
modern system is very very challenging
ancient beer has some unusual
ingredients such as baking yeast
juniper berries and mugwort it's
constantly thinking outside of the box
how do I bring in all of these elements
and ingredients but how do I still mimic
the steps in order to prepare for his
next group
Travis spends three to four months
researching ancient civilization the
beer I'm working on right now is a
bicycle it was consumed probably at
least 1100 years ago according to the
archaeological record
I think the beer is a is a really
phenomenal lens for viewing history and
viewing culture throughout time because
it really does seem to unify people from
this earliest 8500 BCE to the present
the modern consumer they can come
experience what it was the ancient
people may have been drinking and then
realized that wow they're not all that
different than we are and that's what's
so fascinating we need to watch that
fluidity from one culture to the next
you
[Music]